we take you live now to the national
press club in washington d.c today a
discussion with five-time grammy
award-winning singer and songwriter
james taylor on election reform
and welcome to the national press club
my name is theresa warner and i am the
105th president of the national press
club
we are the world's leading professional
organization for journalists committed
to our professions future through
programming and events such as these
while fostering a free press worldwide
for more information about the national
press club please visit our website
www.press.org
to donate to programs offered to the
public through our national press club
institute journalism institute please
visit press.org
institute
on behalf of our members worldwide i'd
like to welcome our speaker and those of
you attending today's event
our head table includes guest of our
speaker as well as working club
journalists who are members of the
national press club
and if you hear applause in the audience
we would note that members of the
general public are attending so it is
not necessarily a lack of
journalistic objectivity
i'd also like to welcome our c-span and
our public radio audiences
our luncheons are also featured on our
member produced weekly podcast from the
national press club available on itunes
you can also follow the action on
twitter using
npc lunch
after our guest speech concludes i'll
have a q a session and i'll ask as many
questions as time permits now i would
like to introduce our head table guest
and i'd ask each of you here to please
stand briefly as your name is announced
from your right
michael phelps publisher president and
ceo of the washington examiner
doris margulies president editorial
associates
jerry zremensky washington bureau chief
buffalo news and former national press
club president
laura lee producer npr and a new member
to the national press club
kim taylor former director of press for
the boston symphony orchestra and
james's wife
i'm going to skip our speaker here and
next we have donna linewand leger usa
today and former national press club
president
mary lou donahue host artistically
speaking and speakers committee member
who organized today's event
john crumpler guest of the speaker
jonathan salant reporter bloomberg news
former president of the national press
club
mark voino senior associate editor
kiplinger personal finances
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all for joining us here today
i really don't need to introduce james
taylor to you in that we all feel that
we know him and his music
but i'll take a moment to remind you of
how and why
we've come to feel we know him
mr taylor's music embodies the art of
songwriting in its most personal and
universal forms
he is a master at describing specific
even autobiographical situations in a
way that resonates with people from
everywhere
for more than 40 years taylor has been a
compass for his fans articulating
moments of pain and joy
and letting his listeners know that they
are not alone
james taylor has sold close to 100
million albums in his career that is a
very big number
look up to the stars on a clear night
that's what a hundred million looks like
and he sung at iconic and american
locations like carnegie hall fenway park
at president barack obama's inauguration
and at the academy awards he is a
five-time grammy award winner and he was
inducted into the rock and roll hall of
fame in 2000
he is a recipient of the national medal
of arts and even with his busy career
taylor has found time for politics
among the most active in the obama
surrogates in the 2012 campaign james
taylor criss-crossed the country in
support of the president performing
alongside with his wife kim spreading
the campaign message wherever and
whenever he was called upon to do so
james work for the president springs
from a lifetime of engagement and
service to progressive causes and began
in 2008 when taylor performed in large
rallies in five cities in his native
north carolina
his efforts there generated thousands of
volunteers and helped win the state for
the democrats for the first time since
1976.
the last year has been especially busy
for the tailors on the campaign trail
over 50 radio and television interviews
and 40 events in 12 states from concerts
and living rooms and field offices to
opening the final night at the
democratic national convention and rally
in the closing days
of the campaign with the president in
new hampshire
and just yesterday he helped brighten up
washington dc by performing at the
lighting of the national christmas tree
in that moment as in many others his
music was with us as we celebrated the
season our families and our country
ladies and gentlemen i would like to
welcome james taylor
thank you teresa thank you very much and
thank you bill and thank you
susan for these delicious cupcakes fire
and rain cupcakes i
did not go unnoticed i got to fire one
myself
mighty tasty alrighty
um
you know i i titled this thing today uh
uh election reform because i thought i
needed to have a title but actually i
probably know less about election reform
than than pretty much everybody in this
room so
i i will talk a little bit about it
towards the end
um
really it's a what i wanted to do is uh
is describe a pilgrim's progress through
the political as a citizen
engaged in the political process
as a surrogate
um but i'll start actually as i as i
used to start and have started many of
my performances in the past with the
song
this is a song that i it's the earliest
of my song not the first song that i
wrote but because uh that's unlistenable
but uh
uh
and uh but
but this is uh the song uh that i played
for um i'm nervous today but but on this
occasion i was i was clinically nervous
i played for
for uh paul mccartney and george
harrison in 1968 in london in in january
of february i guess of 68 in london i
had been lucky enough to get an
opportunity to
to audition for apple records they were
signing acts at the time
i was 19 years old
i had my guitar and i had this song that
i played for them
i'll play it for you now
[Music]
is that coming across laura
yeah
well it's something in the way she moves
looks my way or calls my name
that seems to leave this troubled world
behind
and if i'm feeling down in blue
or trouble by some foolish game you know
she always seems to make me change my
mind
i feel fine anytime that she's around me
now
she's around me now
almost all the time
you find well you can tell that she's
been with me now
she's been with me now
quite a long long time and i feel fine
[Music]
every now and then the things that i
lead on lose their meaning and i find
myself careening into places where i
should not let me
go
she has a power to go
no one else can find me and the silent
deal remind me of the
happiness and the good times that i know
you know
well i guess i just got to know them
it isn't what she's got to say
[Music]
how she thinks of where she's been
to me the words are nice the way they
sound
[Music]
i like to hear them best that way
it doesn't much matter what they mean
she says them mostly just to calm me
down
i feel fine time that she is around me
now
she's around me now
i guess just about all the time and i
found well you can tell
she's been with me now
she's been with me now
quite a long
but a long long
and i time
fine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so it turned out well i was nervous it
was faster and higher in pitch than i
just played it
i was younger i was uh and i was having
an out-of-body experience being in the
same room as two living beetles it was
amazing
and because i was a huge beatles fan and
uh
and mccartney liked it enough that he
signed me to the label
and uh george harrison liked the song
enough that that he went home and and
wrote it himself
but actually um i i've ripped off so
many beetles tunes in my life that it's
a turnabout is fair play
anyway
so uh how do i get into politics from
being a basically a sort of professional
autobiographer and um
uh i think i i just uh you know and is
it is it false advertising to
sort of attract people for one thing and
then and then uh ask them to pay
attention to something else uh
i i suppose a little bit it is but i i
feel so motivated uh particularly in
these past two elections by
by uh what a wonderful uh president i
feel uh barack obama is and by by uh how
important i think it is that that that
he
he get a chance to govern if that's
possible
with this congress but anyway
um
my father really gave me my politics
probably that happened with a lot of us
here
and
we we grew up in north carolina
um
[Music]
he was a uh
i i'm a yellow dog democrat as he was uh
unapologetic uh uh liberal um a definite
progressive
in my my politics and my beliefs
um
and uh uh in in a way
uh
i sort of think that i was defined in a
i'm surprised to to uh to hear myself
say it but defined by jesse helms
to a certain extent
because in in north carolina in those
days jesse helms owned the only uh tv
station it was wral in raleigh and uh he
would go on at the uh programming was
was thin on the ground
and he would he would go on and deliver
these
uh screeds or harangues uh his these
rants um
and those of us living in chapel hill
north carolina where my father was a as
a
worked for the university of north
carolina he had
he had studied medicine in in cambridge
and massachusetts but
uh and had met my mother there
but he had moved the family back to
north carolina
and uh you know
north chapel hill was sort of a
a
progressive enclave in those
days and jesse helms would refer to it
in on in his tv editorials as communist
hill he'd call it communist hill
and uh we were
we it in a way uh um uh that
uh
you know that sort of defined
it was it was an early point of as an
antagonist i i feel as though he he
helped define me politically
and over the years i've i've tried
unsuccessfully uh a sad uh um uh
succession of north carolina democrats
trying to
unsuccessfully to unseat jesse helms it
was i never managed to do it we never
managed to do it in all those years my
friend john crumpler who is from north
carolina here tonight actually
got my wife kim and i deeply involved in
the obama campaign and he's nodding his
head because as a north carolinian he
knows about jesse helms
anyway
my father and his generation
i i remember the
the first
political campaign that i'm aware of
being my family being enthusiastic about
adlai stevenson over eisenhower back in
56 and
my father and his generation in chapel
hill
were really
they built a bridge and a sort of a a
bridge head
they were pro higher education pro
infrastructure
they were
uh they were liberal in their politics
and progressive
and they uh they were deeply uh anti uh
anti-segregationist and anti-jim crow
uh
and they built uh in in uh the raleigh
durham chapel hill area uh uh something
called the research triangle
uh that depended a lot on on education
on higher education and which has really
paid huge dividends and and in a way
opened the road to the new south as we
think of it today
my father would have been
in 2008 would have been
uh so fiercely proud to see
barack obama elected
in north carolina to see the country to
see the state go for for barack obama
sadly it wasn't to happen again in 2012
although we worked really hard at it
but
anyway
uh
my first uh
my first campaign that i actively was
involved with was um mcgovern in uh 72
and uh i think my wife kim still has the
the
the bumper sticker that says don't blame
me i'm from massachusetts because
i think massachusetts was the only state
to go for mcgovern sadly
but kim also uh took a year off from
between high school and college and and
rang doorbells and and uh and called
people up for for that as a field office
uh
uh hand
there in upper state new york upstate
new york
um
but that was i worked with carol king
and barbra streisand we we did a uh
a couple of concerts three for mcgovern
although actually if you say mcgovern
over and over again it's in six yeah six
eight time it was three four mcgovern
sort of as a as a time signature there
me and carol and barbara streisand uh
and uh in the years since then i've
supported uh um i've gotten involved
with uh a number of uh of people in
massachusetts um uh gary studs uh
um uh ted kennedy i worked on his
campaign um
uh i i worked for elizabeth warren this
past time
um i i worked uh for uh let's see i've
written it down here if i can find it
uh
i
i work for uh dukakis and mondale and
gore and kerry and uh
really a a long list of uh
clinton and uh
jimmy carter i worked on john anderson's
campaign the only non-democrat in the
bunch
um
so
you know it was sort of natural
being so politically active over the
years that that i would get involved in
the
in the campaign of 2008
[Music]
i really uh
i was hugely motivated also by by eight
years of of cheney bush and i i say it
in that order on purpose
those were it was it was a tough time
for me i
i really suffered uh
[Music]
it it it made me deeply ambivalent about
my country
that we would uh choose that uh even if
we may not have actually chosen it but
but if that that that
that that was our
that that's what represented us in the
world um
and i felt as though uh in in
after september 11th the
the uh the
the
the diversion the distraction uh of the
the nation's concern and energy uh into
iraq was uh unpardonable and
uh
i i felt that it was inept
corrupt and opaque uh those are tough
years for me and i was very uh
very deeply motivated to in in 2008 to
see barack obama
this wonderful
sort of a surprise really i couldn't
believe our luck that we had gotten such
an a real person
as as
to make it through the filter system of
our politics so
it meant a lot to me and
i know that it would have meant a huge
amount to my father
so because i think of him often and um
uh and so uh
again in in 2012 uh uh we uh uh kim and
i went on the road for obama
we did a uh as teresa said earlier we
did about three dozen different
events and it it was really uh restored
my faith in the uh
in the country to see
um to meet these people who had
committed themselves to this re-election
campaign it was the largest uh
grassroots event that that um we've ever
seen in this country and
and the people involved were such uh
just fundamentally such good people i
felt that uh it it really meant a lot to
me to be involved in it they were smart
too the people who handled this campaign
they did it really well
and uh they were committed to this
mission and they really carried it out
beautifully
um
i i should say also that although i i am
a
sort of
um
relentless democrat
i do believe that a dialogue between
between a reasonable dialogue between
republicans and democrats is what keeps
this country on on on course and in
balance i think that
you know uh by ourselves uh liberals
would probably steer us towards a sort
of paralyzed nanny state european style
and
and republicans left on their own would
head towards oligarchy and inherited
wealth and power
so i i think that we really do
need a a a strong uh republican party
and a and a and a good uh dialogue
between left and right
but
paralysis paralysis seems to be the
the order of the day and
politics of fear
anyway
i will rant on and on and and i and i
and i promised kim i wouldn't do too
much of that it was a delight being
involved in the campaign the obama
campaign we had a a wonderful time and
uh we went back to north carolina
um
we played uh we played this song a lot
not gonna play the whole thing it's too
long
[Applause]
[Music]
in my mind i'm going to carolina
can't you see the sunshine can't you
just feel the moon shine
it is like a friend of mine
hit me from behind
oh i'm going to
carolina in my mind
[Music]
still i'm on the dark side of the moon
and it looks like it goes on like this
forever
[Music]
you must forgive me
[Music]
if i am going to
carolina in my mind
[Music]
if i'm
alone carolina
[Music]
can't you see
sunshine
can't you just feel the moonshine
cleaning just like a friend of mine
hit
[Music]
yes i'm gone
[Music]
my mind
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right
um i've written very few actually
overtly political songs so uh here come
a couple of them
uh
i'll play the first verse of a song
called line em up which
which actually is just a song about how
things in this life
tend to uh
to line up
um
[Music]
oh
i
remember richard nixon back in 74 and
final scene at the white house door and
the staff lined up
just to say goodbye
tiny tear in his shifty lie he said
nobody knows me
nobody understands
little people have been good to me
oh i'm gonna shake some hands
somebody line over
line them all up
[Music]
line them all up
[Applause]
line them all up
[Applause]
[Music]
not really a song about nixon a verse
about nixon
and how he left office i was fascinated
by to watch him on um on camera
uh
he was at the podium saying goodbye i'm
not a crook farewell
and then he had
a staging uh uh problem he had a um
and i look i i was interested in how
they handled it he nixon had a uh didn't
have a great walk it was sort of
uh if you've seen those depictions of
the evolution of man from the
sort of
coming from the primordial ooze to
and then slowly becoming walking on on
all fours and then and then uh finally
ending on
on the extreme with crow magnum man
walking along there sort of analyzing
everything
nixon's walk was a couple of characters
back from that guy
so they didn't want to focus on it and
he had a long walk so they lined up all
of the white house um uh employees and
he went down the line as sort of like a
receiving line and saying goodbye to all
of them and uh which was really quite
moving and
saying hello and goodbye perhaps for the
for the first and last time and
and then at the end of the line he was
on the helicopter bob was his uncle he
was out of there so
um
this next song uh uh is a a a more
political song it's called slap leather
and it was the first verse uh uh is
about uh ronald reagan leaving uh office
uh which the first thing if i'm not
mistaken someone can perhaps enlighten
me on this but it was my impression that
one of the first things that reagan did
after leaving office was to accept a
speaking engagement in japan for for uh
two million bucks is that right that's
what i that's and and that for some
reason that sort of
that that took me back today it would
just flow off my back like
you know nothing had happened sure
what's more natural but at the time
so
[Music]
take all the money that we need for
school
to keep the people in out the core
spending on a weapon you can never use
make the world a novel that they can
refuse
open the door let the shark men feet
hoover up the future in the land of
green
sail upon a rosa to the japanese
slap feather in here for
[Music]
just about to go myself
[Music]
turn the whole wide world into a tv show
you got the same game wherever you go
you never meet a soul that you don't
already know one long commercial for the
status quo
as if these celebrities are your close
friends as if you knew our story ends
as if you weren't sitting in a room
alone and there was somebody real at the
other end of the telephone
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm just about to dial your number
[Music]
get all worked up and we can go back to
worldwide we'll find something worth
your killing for
tie that yellow ribbon around your eyes
big backs falafel and a side of goddamn
fries
big mac falafel
storm and norman
i used to love a parade
slap
phone love
big mac for lava
just about to go myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so big big mac falafel being
sort of code for
the oversimplification of the of the
arab world and the tendency of american
foreign policy at the time to think that
you could fix a watch with a hammer yeah
big mac falafel
um
yeah uh so
we did we we went on the road we we
and in many ways had our faith in the
american process uh uh and our country
are restored by meeting some wonderful
committed people
uh who really
mean extremely well
uh and and have the future of this
country uh in in their hearts and minds
but um
uh we uh
we we raised um uh the better part of
ten million dollars and um
[Music]
it ain't right you know
again i i don't know a lot about
election reform but it seems to me as
though it breaks into two areas one is
the campaign
and the other is the actual election
itself
fixing the campaign is going to be tough
trying to get the money out of it
[Music]
trying to get some forums for our
uh for
in the place of our debates that that
actually give us a clear idea of of who
the candidate is and what they intend
for the country
that's a difficult and tall order
trying to
streamline it so that it doesn't take
two years to run for public office
[Music]
these are
these are difficult things to accomplish
and
i don't know
how we go about it but it seems as
though there is a side of election
reform the actual election process
itself the day of elections that would
be
reasonably easy to do something about
um for me uh
[Music]
i've just come through an election so as
as of course all of you have probably as
intensely if not more so than i have
because you're you're with the prayers
but
um
it seems
uh it seems as though uh
uh
the to me the vote is is sacred it is
the democratic moment it is the moment
of the the actual act of self-government
is when we choose our
our uh representatives
and uh in
in the american experiment
this democratic
light of the world
it seems to me as though the vote is the
moment
and
why we you know we have a day off for
the
fourth of july for independence day
patriots day washington and lincoln's
birthday uh veterans day we have mlk day
um why can't we get a day off to go to
the polls so that people can really make
it
it just seems
uh you know we we have
there was something like 60 60 63
percent participation of eligible voters
this this last election uh off-year
elections it it's more like 40 percent
so
average them out we get we get 50
percent of our voters to the polls and
that's really
that's not good enough for for what
america is and for what it means for
some reason we're dropping that ball
i think we need a day off for polling we
need to open the polls for a week when
we identify people
when we
when we officially identify people they
should be registered as soon as somebody
has an official
name and address they should be
they should be able to get a note in the
mail that tells them where to go to vote
uh
this business of uh
the question of gerrymandering uh for
congressional districts is is a profound
uh conundrum i don't know
how we fix that
but
but
we we can at least get people to to get
to the polls in greater numbers um
there are a lot of people who in the
country who do want to
go in the other other direction who want
fewer people to vote
and these voter id laws that are in the
in the name of preventing voter fraud
uh
i think it's a solution without a
problem the uh the voter fraud in this
country is is pretty much equal to
either side
um and is so low that uh that
the amount of people who are discouraged
from voting by this new id laws it's
it's just a bad idea in my opinion
also if you're concerned about voter
fraud
a paper trail for diabol voting machines
which one third of our country votes on
some kind of accounting possibility for
die bolt machines so that we can check
every hundredth machine against its
actual paper trail
is a much better and a much
more effective way to insure against
voter fraud you can go on google you can
find 20 different
hacking
experiments that people have performed
on these these machines and diebold
wears its political heart on its sleeve
they're very political there you know
they they contribute huge hugely to
political campaigns
so
a paper trail for dibolt machines would
be an an excellent idea to make sure
that that was not being hacked because
it's been repeatedly proven that it is
embarrassingly easy
to hack the returns of die bolt machines
so that that needs to happen
um
anyway that's the that's the election
reform part of my uh my my speech and i
i'm going to end with a with another
song
that that kim and i sang
when we were out on the
trail kim kim actually thought
until she was about 12 years old she
thought that the picture of fdr on her
grandmother's mantelpiece was her
grandfather she
thought they did look a lot alike but
but
her mother was her grandmother was such
a fervent new dealer that she also
inoculated kim in no small way into
liberal politics it's true
[Music]
for
purple mountain manchester
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come
god
set his grace on
thee
and crown thy good
with brotherhood
from sea to
shining
sea
[Music]
from sea to
is
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so you've shared with us your your love
for politics and how passionate you are
for it have you ever thought about
running for public office
with my personal history
that would be a massacre
[Laughter]
within the last year bonnie rate made
the following comment as far as i can
see we have an auction instead of an
election would you comment on her
observation
you know this citizens united decision
is a disaster it's really the the wrong
direction to head in it's pollutant this
uh you know the
the fact that we can go through two
years of
paying very close attention to who these
two men are and have no idea what mitt
romney's plan for the country was
you know a billion dollars spent on
advertising it's just uh uh
citizens united is a disaster and it it
we
i talked to jim messina who who uh
um you know uh who's so instrumental in
the in in obama's re-election
um organization
uh he feels as though uh uh actually i
hope i'm not speaking out of school to
say this but he he feels that we need a
a a constitutional amendment to protect
vote and voters rights into to
and to also protect our elections from
this the pollution of this amazing
amount of money i agree with bonnie
i don't know if it's an auction but it
certainly is the money is a distraction
it doesn't give us good information
about who these people are
you know
uh noam chomsky who i i um forgive me i
i love him uh
noam chomsky says that uh that the size
of a piece of information is
to make it as short as it is today is an
effective
way of us censoring
that it's a censorship to shorten our
pieces of information because it
basically gives us the opportunity just
to say something that people already
know
you know
uh but
the amount of time that it takes to uh
to uh
to contradict uh a sort of known
uh perceived consensus reality
and uh
received wisdom to to sort of
disassemble that and to build in
someone's mind and with a discussion and
an argument another an alternative way
of seeing things
it just takes much too long for the way
we communicate today
i don't know what to do about that um
but it's that what one of the main
problems that uh that liberals have and
one of the questions we ask ourselves so
frequently is
how do we communicate our message it's
such a good message you know why why
can't we communicate this to people why
can't we tell them what's what we have
in mind
i think it's because
people are looking for simple answers to
complex questions and when you rush in
with a simple answer people will flock
to you you know
that's what i meant when i said fix a
watch with a hammer
um
so uh
that's off of the question the point of
view about the question but you know
that's another amazing thing that reagan
taught us in those in those uh debates
uh you'd you'd ask ronald reagan a
question
and he'd answer the question that he
knew the answer to or that you know he
just
absolutely uh nope no problem whatsoever
smooth and uh and you know you'd say
yeah that's great you know
um
it's uh
it's it's amazing uh uh we see it more
and more often too that you answer the
question that you know and and ask me
the next one please
would you be upset if president obama
compromised too much with the
republicans in order to avoid going over
the fiscal cliff
oh yeah i would be yeah i'd be
i'm
you know
i think it's it's remarkable that that
right after the election we get this
thing that comes right up in our faces
that basically outlines in bold relief
the differences in the two ideas about
how we how we go forward in this country
it's uh it's really excellent timing
and i think that we may have to go over
the cliff
you know if it's forced into it but uh
this
you know this idea that you
[Music]
that you uh bring down the cost of
medicare by making it unavailable to
more people is
is a terrible idea of mr bamers
uh and uh the
uh
the idea of of uh uh
i would be terribly uh upset um
along with many uh of my friends if uh
if if obama compromised too much on on
what needs to happen uh that's called
the fiscal cliff please carry
on do you think that a prominent third
party would help our country
i certainly felt strongly about that
when i supported john anderson in 79
and he was
a large part of uh anderson's campaign
was to sue state
uh
the state ballot um procedure uh into
allowing third parties to have more
access to to the uh the electoral
process
[Music]
i would like to see a third party
available
but
that too seems like a really tall order
yeah
what do you think is the appropriate
role for actors musicians and other
celebrities to play in the political
arena you know i think if you are a
a a really
motivated committed citizen who feels
very strongly about either an issue or a
candidate you get involved you know you
you go out and do it regardless of of
what it means
my
you know as i said i've got this long
history as a as a
yellow dog democrat liberal and i don't
think anyone's surprised to see me and i
think my republican
friends um uh tolerate it and and
largely forgive me for it
but uh i uh
i know there are other people who take a
real hit
um i think bruce springsteen is very
very brave to support obama because i
think a lot of his audience
[Music]
is angered by that and
in a way uh it seems like a form of
selling out i think you have to feel
really strongly about it um
it it can feel like a betrayal to people
to see
uh something politicized um
and that speaks to the nature how how
low politics has has sunk
um that people think of it as a betrayal
but
you know again if you feel strongly i
think you get involved
can you tell us a little bit about what
it was like to perform at the democratic
national convention
well it was in north carolina and i so i
knew what song to play
and uh
uh it wasn't on on being carried that at
that moment by the national uh network
so i i felt uh as though i didn't feel
the stress and the extra burden of being
uh on you know on television which is
which always uh affects me negatively
but um uh so it was good it was nice to
be home it felt like the right thing uh
um
charlotte was um
charlotte was electrified for those uh
for that week it was a it was a great um
convention we we love being there
i'd like to shift a little bit to music
a few music questions here and you
mentioned that your first record label
was apple
and was wondering how much did the
beatles help launch your musical career
well i think just being signed and
allowed to make that first album was
and being the first um
artist signed to their label
was a huge uh
amount of attention for me to get
uh it allowed me to make my first record
and and that got me my next deal with
warner brothers
so it it
i don't i don't think that the beatles
themselves were in any way
charged with the mission of publicizing
james taylor i i think the
signing me was enough so
yeah what do you think is your secret
for your long success
oh uh i've got a great audience then and
i love them i love the people who come
and see me um
they've supported me for such a long
time and they're so uh
you know they they are
they as well are lovely people and i i
feel uh
very at home very comfortable with them
as i said increasingly grateful as time
goes by
and that and uh just uh
the the great good fortune of of being
uh healthy
and um again it's also a kind of music
that doesn't tear you up to sing it you
know there are some people who you hear
you you hear kurt cobain saying and you
say
how's that going to feel at the age of
50 you know
now sadly we didn't get a chance to see
and i'm sure that it would have changed
into something that would have been uh
beautiful and worthy but
uh you know uh it's
this it's a it's a kind of music that
that lets you carry on with it so um
uh you know it's
it's
it all comes down to good luck
you're known for your incredible solo
career but you've also done duets such
as with tony bennett natalie cole who is
your favorite duet partner
oh
do i get in trouble for this
uh
there there haven't been all that many
so i can mention all of them aside from
i i loved working with mark knopfler on
on
sailing to philadelphia
with allison krauss on that beautiful
leuven brothers uh
tribute that she did
uh
linda ronstadt
oh there are there are many um
of course carol king joni mitchell
uh
i don't know they're all it's it's
impossible to choose
is there anyone that you would like to
perform with that you haven't
um
[Music]
i'd like to perform with harry belafonte
if i could i tried i asked him we did a
series of concerts at uh at carnegie
hall and uh
i asked ton uh
harry if he would
if he'd sing uh um
uh
one of the songs that i grew up
listening to with his but
he's uh he's pretty
um he's pretty much decided he's not
going to do that anymore but
yeah
harry belafonte
what was the first song that you could
truly play on the guitar
keep on trucking mama
can you still play it can i still play
it
you don't want to hear that
this is where things go south yeah
[Music]
keep on trucking mama
talking my blues away
keep on trucking mom
until a brigade
etc
did you take lessons or are you
self-taught on the guitar i'm
self-taught on the guitar um i but a lot
of people showed me stuff um they
weren't formal lessons but they were uh
you know
that's how it how it
worked um in the great folk scare of the
mid 60s as we call it
you know
but uh
uh we did we um
we we would
sort of share licks and
everybody walk around with guitar all
the time we thought that was normal
[Music]
your playing style has always seemed
deceptively relaxed using your thumb
forefinger and middle finger and your
picking did you develop that style on
your own or were you influenced by
anyone
i was influenced by a guy named uh
travis uh
merle travis and he had something called
travis picking although he probably
learned it from someone else himself it
was sort of a
kind of a walking base
like
that's that was my improv i threw in
this finger
so um that that's what was the beginning
of it but it's a sort of a
it allows you to play
a bass line and it's sort of a pianistic
style because you can play the left hand
with your thumb and your right hand with
your your other fingers
what gave you the idea to do a slow
version of handyman originally by jimmy
jones it was really funny you know uh we
were in the studio making a new album we
were cutting our in our first day of
tracking we got three different songs
recorded songs that i had written and
we're ready to
to for us to put down what we call basic
tracks and then you come back and you
sing the the finished vocal on it or put
other elements on it uh on in an overdub
but
we finished these three songs and we
still had like an hour and a half of
studio time left before the meter ran
out um
and uh
my friend danny korchmar
said uh you know you always like that
song handyman why don't we why don't we
do a version of that we whipped it up
there in about 15 minutes just came up
with a quick um
[Music]
james taylor eyes version of it and uh
and that's how it went down it was
really off the just off the cuff off the
top of our heads
inspired you to write sweet baby james
well it was a song for my my nephew who
was the first uh
child born
in our family in our generation
named after me by my brother alex i had
been overseas i'd been abroad
uh making my my apple album when i came
home i was really keen to see the little
baby
and uh i drove down to north carolina
and kept thinking about wouldn't it be
nice to have a sort of cowboy lullaby
to sing this little
new little baby james and uh like
roy rogers or gene autry kind of
it'll be blue shadows on the trail or
uh
go to sleep you little buckaroo
you know kind of thing and that was the
idea but behind it it was uh willie's a
young cowboy
living on a race
his horse and his cattle there is only
companions
he works in the saddle and he sleeps in
the canyons just waiting for summer his
pastures to change
[Applause]
oh when as the moon rises he sits by his
fire just to thinking about women and
glasses of beer
and clothes in his eyes as the doggies
are tired
he sings out a song which is soft but
it's clear
just as if maybe someone could hear
[Music]
he says good night all your moonlight
ladies
brocco by my sweet baby js
[Music]
[Applause]
deep greens and blues for the colors i
choose won't you let me go down in my
dreams
yes and rock on by my sweet baby james
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry i turned off my amplifier
everything
if if this is live for three minutes it
says is that how much time we've got
left i'm told they uh we're also
enthralled with you we can run a little
longer if you want to keep going a
little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
people dashing for the door
lock them in
most songwriters will say that their
songs are like children but do you have
a favorite song that you've written
that one that one i think yeah
mike uh it
says there's a song that they sing when
they take to the highway
and a song that they sing when they take
to the scene
a song that they sing of their home in
the sky
maybe you can't believe it it might help
you to sleep
and the singing seems to work fine for
me
[Music]
baby james
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you still write your songs down with
paper and pencil yes i do um i i carry a
little i've always carried a little
recording device of some sort they used
to be pretty big but
now
now they're quite small and
i
i
i always carry a
pen and paper and i'm ready in case
something occurs to me you mentioned uh
merle travis influenced you on your your
guitar playing style what other
musicians were influences on you
rye cooter is uh is still my favorite
guitar player although there are many
many to choose from but
there's an album of his called paradise
and lunch
which was uh
such a uh
you know so formative for me there was a
a guy when i was coming up named tom
rush
who played here at the cellar door
and he played in boston at the 47.
he was
i really patterned myself after tom
just a guy with a guitar
folk folk musician unapologetic folk
musician
and
i'd say those those two and the beatles
what do you think of current pop music
you know i um
i guess i don't like it a whole lot
i think i'm a lot
what would we find
i sound just like my dad i just just
like my dad you know
there is some there's there are great
people out there i know it and uh and i
don't mean to to condemn it blanket
condemn it but
you know
it seems i think it's passed me by a
little bit the sort of i still have a
wonderful career and a beautiful
audience that that i that i really i
really love
uh
but you know the the
the the spotlight is on is elsewhere now
and uh i'm a sort of known quantity now
and that's fine with me to sort of play
out this hand um
uh
you know i i but i don't i don't uh pay
a a whole lot of attention to i never
did listen much to the radio you know
when i was a kid i was really young i
did but
um you know and i i don't listen to
music much uh
kim
works with the boston symphony and
therefore we get a lot of classical
music in the house i have two 11 year
old kim and i have 11 year old twin boys
and they have their preferences
maybe that's maybe it's it's because
they're playing most of the popular
music i'm hearing in the house
i've got such a negative take on it
anyway
do you have an ipod
uh not an ipod no i ipad i've had do you
have music selections on there
no no i don't listen to my music on
computer really
i i listen on cd and uh and um and vinyl
so it said that uh singer taylor swift
is named after you what do you think of
her music i do like taylor's music and
she's uh she's my great name and i've
had because yes i like the name too
i i do think she is a creative
singer-songwriter you know it's season a
remarkable sort of marketing phenomenon
and if she can survive that and i mean
it it's a hard thing to survive i think
um
but she seems to have a very
clear uh
head on our shoulders and i think if
anyone can she can make it through and
continue to evolve as a as an artist and
um
because it's the the
the sort of the marketing hit is if
you're lucky enough to be successful
that's a
that
particular
passage that
an artist has to make if if he's lucky
enough or she's lucky enough
is it can be a real jarring
life-changing event it can really shake
you up you know but going from being
very private to being very public
yeah
many people have said that daniel
day-lewis's portrayal of lincoln and the
current film reminds them of you
do you have any comment on that
and i hear you i hear you've seen the
movie i have seen the movie he doesn't
look like me to me but i live in here
you know so
i live in here so a map to notice the
difference you know
uh
you know john williams uh who
who is a dear friend and uh
this generation's remarkable musician
orchestral musician
and composer
uh john wanted me to to play that part
he actually stood up for me there
suggested me at one point was never
going to happen but
so i don't know uh i'm i'm flattered uh
i uh of course everybody um
loves lincoln i i do i
um but i i don't see
um
[Music]
other than the fact that we're both tall
and somewhat skinny
you know and
he speaks much better in public than i
do
is there is there a role you would like
to play
no no this is fine
this is fine it's very it is very
unusual i've spent my life being myself
for a living
and and i think more than than really uh
more than anyone else i think i know
that i
i think there are performers who
develop and assume a character
that they then
play for the the public
but
i don't know anyone who is
as much to themselves publicly for
living as as uh as i am so it's been an
interesting ride it's been uh but i
don't think i'm qualified to really uh
understand it
well no
okay several people sent this question
up so i i feel obligated to ask do you
know who carly simon was thinking about
in you're so vain
and will you share that with us i think
it's warren beatty
and he says not yeah okay so
that's that's
that's what my information was but again
that information has not been updated
for 40 years
now that the turnpike from stockbridge
to boston extends past the city to the
airport thanks to the big dig any thongs
any thoughts about revising the song
oh you mean that that
the turnpike no longer ends in boston
and it goes all the way to
somerset no uh
quincy
uh
what what what town is the is the
airport
in stockbridge to chelsea it's got a
ring to it but it doesn't it doesn't
rhyme with frosting
see that's the thing is the internal
rhyme
now
that song has a it has four rhyming
schemes going at once
uh
first of december was covered with snow
so it was a turnpike from stockton to
boston
frostin
ten miles behind me and ten thousand
more to go to rhyme with snow
so it it
it's got to be boston
unless they take it to austin texas
i want to thank all of you for for
joining us this afternoon this has been
absolutely terrific and i want to remind
you of our next upcoming lunch on
december 18th we have leon panetta the
secretary of the u.s department of
defense i'm sure if you have some advice
on how to solve the physical cliff he'd
be happy to hear that and uh while
you're writing our next song i'd like to
present you with our famous press club
coffee mug i think that will go well
with uh
with your songwriting and guitar playing
it might give you some inspiration
[Music]
thank you so much thank you
[Music]
so thank all of you for coming today i
want to thank the national press club
staff including our journalism institute
and broadcast center for organizing
today's event and a reminder that you
can find more information at www.press
and i was wondering if you had one last
song that perhaps you'd like to sing us
out on
[Music]
he looks like he's up for want to sing
come join him oh come on
can she borrow your stool
[Applause]
this is my wife kim
and here's here's a song we sing
a song that we sing to our
to our our twin boys actually
about two years ago i we
we went in to sing them to sleep with
this lullaby and
um
[Music]
we got the guitar out sat down on the
side of the bed uh and uh we're about to
play the opening chords and and rufus
looked up at me and said you know dad we
don't have to do this anymore
[Music]
all sun is your
sinking
now
but the moon is slowly rising
so this whole world
[Music]
would you close your
[Music]
i can't sing the blues
anymore
[Applause]
sure but i can sing this song
for when you can sing this song
when i'm gone
though it won't be long
for another day
[Applause]
[Music]
and no one's going to take that time
away
you can stay as long as you like
only close your
eyes
you can close your eyes it's all right
i know i don't know no love songs
i can't sing
grooves anymore
sure but i can sing this song
and he can sing this song
when i'm gone
[Music]
she's a game gal
[Music]
goodbye and thank you very much
thank you so much
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yes
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
georgia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well i'm glad enjoyed it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um